Sean and Catherine Lowe are expecting  that's right a bachelor baby is on the  way  Sean and Catherine announced the big  news on Instagram on Tuesday  Sean posted this shot writing quote it's  happening I'm going to be a dad  Catherine went with this photo and  simply said quote hey baby  the pair met during season 17 of The  Bachelor and tied the knot in a  televised wedding special in January  2014 just last week the couple played  coy about their baby plans but told ET  not to expect to see their kids on TV  one day we're gonna have a family and  we're not gonna throw our kids and for  the cameras and do crazy stuff like that  like I think I think that chapter that  next chapter of our lives will probably  be pretty private yeah  all right guys if you have any baby name  ideas for them send them my way  and of course include that et now  hashtag in your tweet